.
>> Sean: JESSE WATTERS, THANK
YOU.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
BREAKING TONIGHT A BOMBSHELL NEW
DEVELOPMENT IN THE DURHAM PROBE.
ONE OF CHRISTOPHER STEELE'S
PRIMARY SOURCES, IN THIS CASE
A RUSSIAN ANALYST WAS INDICTED.
WHAT THIS COULD MEAN FOR HILLARY
CLINTON.
COMEY AND OTHER HIGH LEVEL
ACTORS THAT PUSHED THE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION HOAX FOR 5 YEARS.
DURHAM MAY HAVE FIGURED THIS
OUT.
WHO SHOULD BE WORRIED TONIGHT?
WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH DEMOCRATS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY THEY ARE
STILL REELING FROM THIS MAJOR
ELECTION LOSS ON TUESDAY, IN
VIRGINIA AND NEW JERSEY AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
EVEN IN NEW JERSEY THE
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE JACK
CIATTARELLI IS WITHIN 2 POINTS
OF THE DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR AND
NO ONE HAS CONCEDED.
DEMOCRATIC DENIAL IS WORSE AND
JOE BIDEN GREEN NEW DEAL IS IN
JEOPARDY.
ONE PERSON SAID CAPITOL HILL IS
AN ADAM SCHIFF SHOW.
SOME MEDIA MOBSTERS ARE BLAMING
RACIST AMERICANS WHO LOVE WHITE
SUPREMACY.
THAT'S HARD TO EXPLAIN
CONSIDERING SOME OF THE WINS ON
TUESDAY AND IGNORING THE
HISTORIC ELECTION.
WINSOME SEARS WAS ON THIS SHOW
LAST NIGHT.
AND OTHERS LIKE ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ ARE BLAMING
MEMBERS OF THEIR OWN PARTY.
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT RADICAL
ENOUGH.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I KNOW THAT VIRGINIA WAS
A HUGE BUMMER.
IF ANYTHING, I THINK THE RESULTS
SHOW THE LIMITS OF TRYING TO RUN
A FULLY 100% SUPER MODERATE
CAMPAIGN.
THAT DOESN'T EXCITE, SPEAK TO OR
ENERGIZE THE PROGRESSIVE BASE.
WE WERE NOT INVITED TO
CONTRIBUTE IN THAT RACE.
>> Sean: CLIMATE CHANGE RANKED
AT THE BOTTOM OF THE ISSUES.
FOR EXAMPLE, VOTERS IN VIRGINIA
CARED ABOUT.
THE ECONOMY AND EDUCATION AND
TAXES WERE AT THE TOP OF THE
LIST.
FOR SOMEONE THAT THINKS THE
WORLD IS GOING TO END IN 10
YEARS, LOGIC IS NOT NECESSARILY
A TOP PRIORITY.
STILL PELOSI, SCHUMER, BIDEN ARE
GETTING BULLIED BY AOC AND THE
SQUAD.
THEY WERE RIGHT BACK PUSHING
THEIR RADICAL AGENDA TODAY.
TRIPLING DOWN ON THE BUILD BACK
BETTER SOCIALIST SPENDING ORGY.
AND THE TRUE COST OF BUILD BACK
BETTER SOCIALISM IS OVER 4
TRILLION DOLLARS.
CREDIT TO JOE MANCHIN WHO SAID
GET RID OF ALL OF THE ACCOUNTING
GIMMICKS AND GIVE US REAL
NUMBERS SO WE CAN VOTE ON AN
HONEST BILL.
THAT IS NOT LIKELY TO HAPPEN.
AND THAT WILL BE 3 TRILLION
DOLLARS PRINTED OR JUST ADDED TO
THE DEBT AND INFLATION WILL SKY
ROCKET ON TOP OF THE HISTORIC
LEVELS OF INFLATION ALL OF US
ARE NOW SUFFERING THROUGH.
AND RECORD HIGH ENERGY PRICES
AND EVERYTHING YOU BUY AT EVERY
STORY IS MUCH HIGHER.
THE PLAN CALLED FOR 185 TIMES
MORE SPENDING ON CLIMATE THAN ON
FUTURE PANDEMIC PREPAREDNESS.
DOES THAT MAKE SENSE.
SENATOR JOE MANCHIN DOESN'T
APPEAR TO BE ON BOARD.
CALLED THE VIRGINIA RESULTS
A WAKE UP CALL.
HE IS RIGHT AND TODAY MANCHIN
TELLS FAKE NEWS CNN THAT AMERICA
IS NOT A CENTER LEFT COUNTRY BUT
A CENTER RIGHT COUNTRY.
CONGRESS BETTER TAKE NOTE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE HAVE TO WORK TOGETHER.
WE CAN'T GO TOO FAR LEFT.
THIS IS NOT A CENTER LEFT OR
A LEFT COUNTRY.
WE ARE CENTER, IF ANYTHING
CENTER RIGHT.
WE OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO RECOGNIZE
THAT.
ALL MY FRIENDS ON THE LEFT, THE
PROGRESSIVES AND LIBERALS, I AM
NOT.
>> Sean: HE AND KRYSTEN SINEMA
ARE ABOUT THE ONLY 2 IN THE
SENATE THAT RECOGNIZE THE
OBVIOUS.
IN THE HOUSE ONE VIRGINIA
DEMOCRAT SEEING THE HAND WRITING
ON THE WALL AND BLASTED HER
COLLEAGUES FOR IGNORING REAL
PROBLEMS LIKE INFLATION AND THE
HIGH COST OF ENERGY AND THE
SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES.
TRASHING BUILD BACK BETTER,
SAYING NOBODY ELECTED JOE BIDEN
TO BE FDR.
AND A DEMOCRATIC STRATEGIST WHO
IS SMART BUT A DINOSAUR IN TERMS
OF HIS WAY OF THINKING WHICH IS
MORE CENTER LEFT BUT PARTLY
CENTER.
JAMES CARVILLE BELIEVES HIS
PARTY LOST ITS WAY AND HE IS
CORRECT.
>> WHAT WENT WRONG?
>> DON'T JUST LOOK AT VIRGINIA
AND NEW JERSEY.
LOOK AT LONG ISLAND AND SEATTLE,
WASHINGTON.
THIS DEFUND POLICE LUNACY AND
TAKE LINCOLN'S NAME OFF OF
SCHOOLS.
PEOPLE SEE THAT.
IT'S HAVING A SUPPRESSIVE EFFECT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
SOME PEOPLE NEED TO GO TO A WOKE
DETOX CENTER.
>> Sean: I THINK I FINALLY WON
JAMES OVER.
STUPID WOKENESS.
CARVILLE IS RIGHT.
THE RADICAL SOCIALISTS RULE THE
PARTY.
THEY ARE NOT GOING ANYWHERE.
THEY NOW RULE THE ENTIRE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THEY DO SO
WITH AN IRON FIST.
BIDEN'S WOKE DOJ LED BY GARLAND
WILL ISSUE 6-FIGURE PAYMENTS TO
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
YESTERDAY A BEWILDERED AND
BEFUDDLED JOE BIDEN DENIED ANY
PLAN WAS IN THE WORKS.
AS IT TURNS OUT, JOE WAS NOT IN
THE LOOP AS USUAL.
TODAY HIS DEPUTY PRESS SECRETARY
SAID BIDEN SUPPORTS THESE
PAYMENTS.
OUR OWN PETER DOOCY WAS CORRECT
AGAIN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS COMFORTABLE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
SETTLING WITH THE INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES WHO ARE CURRENTLY
IN LITIGATION WITH THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT.
THE DOJ CAN SPEAK MORE ON THAT
PROCESS.
>> Sean: WHILE YOU STRUGGLE WITH
RISING GAS AND FOOD PRICES AND
HOUSING AND TRANSPORTATION
COSTS.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
CUTTING HUGE CHECKS, $450,000 TO
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
THEY WILL GET HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS EACH OUT OF
YOUR POCKET.
PEOPLE THAT DIDN'T RESPECT OUR
LAWS.
DID NOT RESPECT OUR BORDERS OR
OUR SOVEREIGNTY AND ENTERED THIS
COUNTRY ULLEGALLY.
-- ILLEGALLY.
THAT'S MADNESS AND INSANITY.
WELCOME TO AMERICA LAST POLICY.
FORGET AMERICA FIRST.
THIS IS AMERICA THE SUCKER
NATION THAT ALLOWS CHINA AND
INDIA TO BE CLASSIFIED AS
DEVELOPING NATIONS AND WE PAY
EVERYTHING FOR THE PARIS CLIMATE
ACCORDS.
CHINA IS MOCKING JOE BIDEN FOR
BEING POWERLESS.
JOE FALLS ASLEEP AND APOLOGIZEDS
JUST LIKE HIS IDOL BARACK OBAMA
FOR AMERICA.
HE HAS NO CLUE HIS OWN STATE
DEPARTMENT IS PLANNING ON
PLAYING ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
$450,000 EACH.
HE GOES BACK AGAIN TO BEG OPEC
AND RUSSIA TO PRODUCE MORE OIL.
JOE, ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS ASK
TEXAS, ALASKA, NORTH DAKOTA,
OKLAHOMA.
THEY WILL BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
ACCOMMODATE.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS DEMOCRATS,
WHO ARE THEY HURTING?
THE POOR AND THE MIDDLE-CLASS.
I THOUGHT NOBODY WAS GOING TO
PAY A PENNY MORE IF THEY MADE
UNDER $400,000 A YEAR.
NOPE.
THE PEOPLE BEARING THE BRUNT OF
THESE POLICY ARE THE POO